and the masters of the universe okay
cool lovely stuff i love that we've got
a hand up here it's gentlemen the
creator t-shirt
torturing the donkey
ask more questions the first one very
simple that's a pop culture reference
understand this one i don't want to ask
any more questions about how that
possibly came on right let's come to uh
yes hand up here because all the
suggestions come from sorry people who
sat at the back yeah
[Music]
music oh west coast sorry if my head
glasgow's rap music was definitely a
much better suggestion
i hope you don't mind i'm going to take
a dealer's choice and say that i am
co-opting your suggestion of making a
glasgow rap music about scottish history
that's what i'm going to do for that
castle great school torturing adventure
let's come to the back of the room over
here
from you yeah yeah uh
so what's fun if you if you were just
here because you were like let's go see
a show and you have you're just like why
aren't people just suggesting things
like pizza and dogs
but it's because there's these people
definitely right
they they watch everything i put online
and they go oh let's try and catch them
out or let's try and do something really
weird
that's why they're all massive losers
with nothing better to do
in the best possible way i include
myself in that smear test freddy krueger
and there
do you mean the economic decline of
no because venezuela a different meaning
right if you're like vegetarian was very
economical by it it happened reasonably
quickly right um the economic decline of
venezuela a smear test from freddy
krueger torturing a computer death of a
fairy duster castle
skull glad to go rap music in scottish
history that is the the we'll throw that
in there as well yes i
i feel like this is definitely not the
moment to go for a piss but it's because
this is the best bit this apart from the
bit of the end that's the best bit but
this is this is a freestyle about all
those things you might need to remind me
because there's so many big words in
there let's uh let this be let's have
some fun i'm really excited thank you
the suggestions if the wrap is [ __ ] it's
entirely my fault so let's uh let's do
this
be alive when he-man turns up and he
wears a castle
that's the four-person skeletor he's
banging there on the pearl colors on the
turtle i used to have a playset sitting
down on the carpet picking on worlds of
how to start
[Music]
street that's my favorite place made by
new line cinema that's a true fact for
us with this blades on it i know he knew
that but actually he went to more
behavior himself worked in the medical
door like of course i wanna
[Music]
[Music]
it makes a lot of sense
[Applause]
he doesn't spoil it he doesn't get the
cash from oil like a south american
country that stays there i've persuaded
venezuela
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
glasgow
[Music]
genuinely a glaswegian venue a bloody
love glasgow there on a saturday next
weekend doing shows yeah flattering and
there we go i'm calling a truce between
me me the scottish guys and you and do
the freestyle up you know i produce a
freestyle rap about robert the bruce